before this video begins here I am sorry
about the mess it doesn't matter I am a
very important exciting announcement me
and Mark says latest collection rookie
is out now it's this clothing brand that
we made together this is our third
collection and it's my favorite one so
far here's a glorious picture of me
wearing the long-sleeve shirt it's got a
cool print on the back I absolutely love
how this one turn out so all these
pieces aren't designed by me and Marcia
together they're all custom fitted there
are we call the patterns we call the
fabrics and then there may Emily as well
so it's not a mass-produced thing it's
an actual clothing brand as opposed to
merch
we're very excited about this is the
goodie you know what marks it looks 10
times fight over them it's about the
show her very cute we also have a really
nice comfy oversized hoodie all the
pieces are very comfy we have this
overall I call it overall but my sense
is not hold over run through the side
pegs on it all the buttons are custom
everything is custom I love the jacket
that we designed it's so cool it's a
pullover I love how the back term that
it's such a cool jacket we also have a
scarf with the scent bags on it and of
course a t-shirt super cool a lot of
this design turnout as well and of
course the pants finally have hands that
fit me well these are so awesome so good
looking alone of Easter know you guys
want to check it out link is in the
description and support Sookie and the
brand and vision that we have I can't
wait to see what else we do in the
future as well but this is it enjoy the
video thank you guys good the ye time
how's it going brows it's me
PewDiePie brows brows what's up brows
down you're out what's up how's it going
worth it to Lorraine
[Music]
[Applause]
YouTube's favorite show everybody that's
right last week we hit trending
just kidding only PC bullshit's gets on
trending like if you're a lipped hard
less review than the wife
[Music]
yo 4.2 k people online
that's a sexual number oh my god water
are great oh no this is why I avoid
bridges too much traffic
when are you gonna let that go you know
I'm good thinking about this and I will
have to say it's equally Brian's fault
sorry but as it was mine if not more it
was branchspell what was he doing at the
middle of the goddamn break
I have clearly already passed safely and
you know what if it wasn't for Brad
being idiot I sort of never have
happened
I couldn't still be live-streaming huh
that's gonna be my next apologies you
know what it was Brian's full looking at
me teams inside the EU Parliament it
will be the only plays you can look at
memes hurricane Michael bus the world's
biggest but great they're just shoving
it into our faces aren't they Hey look
at look what I'm doing
ha ha ha this is both why why you have
to bend memes this is so sad I can't
have the audio I'll just I'll just my
mother
[Music]
really hasn't even been a year and
you're thinking it's okay to me my dead
pet s MH I'm shaking okay great so far
we have people bullying me for my
controversies in my my disease loved
ones isn't it great to have a community
thank you guys so much I love you guys
so much
I'm not like all these other fans f what
good is it call you tubers that what I
am me and McDonald's can have a tracer
I'm already tracer okay okay that was
good now I kind of wish I was working at
McDonald's just so I can pull that on
the people wouldn't be epic if I just
started working at McDonald's just so I
can do that mean
never forget that Felix made a channel
as a joke it got over a million subs and
then he deleted it like it was nothing
well I made a promise that I was gonna
leave my channel right haha so clever
that Danny DeVito in the back god damn
I'm doing my part from Bangladesh thank
you ain't it I'm just kidding
someone informed me on Twitter that my
merch if you're a true Bangladeshi
insane you buy the new merch okay
very epic thank you Bangladesh how do I
save something nice in Bangladesh Aparna
care dhanyavad are valid esse broza not
all heroes wear capes come on do
something okay Timmy they're catching up
a kick well thought we were winning if
they pass us all efforts will be in vain
do something everyone do something but
me thank you please mister piece I just
need one more help one more last final
push
right me this one wish mommy can you
give me money to buy memes yes
actually buys groceries like a bus
trolley time SNH sir this is photo shop
this is photo shop everyone knows I
don't have legs I don't believe in legs
I will never believe in legs stop the
bullying you see this not King Hill
goddamn legend I'll link the real
version just so you guys can hear it
with audio cuz it's pretty awesome
I need the 9 year old army to hold out
for a while I have something big plan
but I need time there is hope thank you
mr. B's arigato I knew it I knew he
wouldn't let us down mr. B's is cooking
up something what could it be they say
guys literally only they say guys
literally only want one thing and it's
disgusting
Rachel hi hi thanks for the match I need
you for one thing only
it starts with S and ends with X such a
bad joke subscribe to feel get baited
Rachel what do you think he wanted you
pathetic go subscribe Rachel if anyone
watching this and named Rachel aims to
subscribe yet a laugh at you haha this
guy won't leave my backyard he kept
asking for lasagna what do I do another
Photoshop another Photoshop I don't have
legs I don't know how many times I gotta
tell you guys what do you find these
photos can I not visit my backyard go
for a handshake that'll make him stop
the bullying I worked out of school and
I'm going to get fired for this Jesus
Christ but all I wish was for peers to
see subscribe to pity pot I'm doing my
part
it's so beautiful to see everyone taking
every part they can for
mascots for a good cause for the greater
cost of humankind god Bless You Saachi
the whack ongoing war between PDP and
t-series markiplier and jacksepticeye oh
I didn't want to start the drama I
didn't want to be the one that pointed
it out but this is another classic
example of people not using their voice
when a little bit of controversy when a
little bit of spicy spit I see hits the
fan I see how it is I understand it's
okay I'm not sad or angry just
disappointed oh my god
oh my god
[Music]
yeah
Jesus Christ
the new acts out for everybody Wow very
good
this is stupid image of me come on I
need to play some animal super squad man
it looks great Matt Brad one and Brad
two better put this in low I we here's a
mean review in class to raise awareness
Wow
thank you Sarah Bush for 20 even though
the professor was confused af2 please
help us that he'll see this we are doing
our part here in Slovenia amazing Thank
You Russia very cool
I don't think that nine girls will get
this but I have hopes well I get it and
I don't like it
the gods have spoken pity pipe
disrespecting women Pete by respecting
me did you mean Petey by respecting
women this is what I'm talking about
fake news and articles everywhere you
can't contest with a Petey pie look at
that look at that look at that son you
ever come and tell me I don't respect
women now where was it never be violent
to women Mark Zuckerberg always looked
like the guy in a zombie movie who's
been bitten but it's trying to keep it a
secret from everyone
hey look at that we're still doing suck
memes everyone how about that
I miss suck I miss when he was in the in
the spotlight you know he's blessed us
with so many great memes I was over a
year ago God can vote now
we should make PewDiePie play for at
night when Linda so he gets an
eight-year-olds to sub to that exchange
and I never played before tonight it's
the one thing it's the one shed of
integrity I have left that I will not
conform to play this a really popular
video game just for the sake of use the
goddamnit I'm desperate a hero has come
forward saving PD PI from D Series
CaptainSparklez is this real
now if you're a cultured person of the
internet like myself you're probably
aware of a battle that's been raging for
quite some time now that is the battle
for the number one most subscribed slot
on YouTube it's a title that's been held
for many years by PewDiePie right now
he's sitting at seven
million 876 thousand 731 subscribers and
Counting let's change that plus one with
all his channel decision the Jordan
games channel one that I decided that
seven it's describing with all those
channels right now we move over to
fortnight cinema subscribe thank you
thank you captain sparkles very cool
this is what I'm talking about taking
the extra mile doing just a little bit
more than the average person that's all
I ask
coach Malone would prompt prep probably
would probably you absolutely
anyway would probably host me review if
huge invited him oh that's right Takeshi
six nine is going to jail for life
a Takeshi could you like host me review
from prison or something that'd be epic
Takeshi could face life in prison due to
criminal charges Takeshi before you go
to prison please one favor just one
small thing please Peter pie will you
want a cartoon like that I'm ready to do
it correct damn that's sick
I'll stay pay that's amazing I mean you
wouldn't that's amazing bbm gee that
looks so cool
and like and like a scythe never gets
depicted
yeah poor man getting dr. Phil to host
meme review okay alright okay getting
huge to host dr. Phil hyper so damn that
would be a bit
I would love time nickel and on or have
all of them on we have Nicolette will
have vegan Jesus or everything was and
all those all those guys as you can see
I purchased all the billboards are in
India to promote PewDiePie and pewdiepie
I know you are watching this video I'm
totally not doing this so that you can
react to this video on your channel that
is really not the reason but be great if
you do it so please do it please
PewDiePie I need subscribers okay
fair enough
[Music]
so for the sake of YouTube please
subscribe to purify because if you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you're welcome Simon Says thank you
very cool I mean thank you India very
cool now subscribe to PewDiePie and
unsubscribe from t-series that's all
they ask
thank you guys for watching another
episode of look why YouTube's favorite
show everybody see you guys next week
submit memes down below become that's it
[Music]
[Applause]